[Music]
let me tell you about the time
that i forgot my dad's birthday it was a
few years ago and i'd woken up with
large bags under my eyes
the true mark of a grey's anatomy binge
i reach out to my phone to shut my alarm
and i'm greeted with a stream of
notifications
texts emails friends family social media
news
even my meditation app was grasping for
my attention
and so i did what i'd done a thousand
times before
i sat in bed and mindlessly scrolled
and this happened throughout the day i
felt present in my interactions but at
every buzz
ping and moment of free time i would
reach out for my phone
and so when my dad called me later that
day i looked at the time and it finally
hit me
that i was behind on work and so i
ignored his phone call
and decided that i would be productive i
put my phone away and opened my computer
and that's when it began again later
when i found out
that i missed his birthday i felt so
guilty i had reached a new low
that was the day that i came to terms
with my technology addiction
and so i did what most people say is the
solution to this addiction
i deleted social media and distanced
myself as far as possible from
technology
and for a while i felt great in fact i
was successfully unplugged for two years
but the longer that i was off the grid
the more i miss out on
i'm missing photos of my friends i'm
just staying up to date with the latest
pop culture
and i miss learning about the world
through others
my tech addiction and my digital detox
taught me
that we can expect individuals to take
isolated actions
that will lead to collective societal
change
we need to shift the responsibility from
responsible tech usage
to responsible tech creation
don't get me wrong technology is a
powerful force for good
over the last few years i've worked on
products that have touched
hundreds and millions of users and i've
seen firsthand the transformative power
of technology technology has
revolutionized our world
and made our daily lives easier it has
connected us
brought us joy and entertainment and
insparked our creativities in new ways
it will lengthen our lives and improve
our quality of care
but i also understand that there's a
cost to all of that
and truthfully i worry that in trying to
solve
some problems i will create even more
because it's not just me a lot of us
have difficulty stepping away from the
products we love
we spend five hours a day consuming
digital content
and 12 hours a day in front of a screen
that's half
of our lives and it's not just tech
addiction
over the last few years we've seen the
impact of technology all around us
from misinformation and polarization ai
bias
and privacy infringements the potential
to fuel our anxiety and depression the
potential to radicalize individuals and
destroy our democracy
all rooted in this perpetual dependence
left unchecked technology and its
downstream effects
are poised to be the greatest public
health crisis of our century
so how do we get the good without the
bad
well i've always believed that looking
at where we've been
can help us get to where we need to be
so let's take a look at a public health
crisis of last century
cars in the early 1900s
cars replaced horse-drawn carriages
bringing a wave of possibility
but over time more and more cars were on
the road and these cars were able to go
faster and faster
drivers didn't have licenses age limits
or sobriety requirements
cars didn't have seat belts airbags or
mirrors
and roads didn't have speed limits
traffic lights or crosswalks
the result people were dying at its peak
there were 35 deaths for every 10 000
cars
for context today this number is one
once a beacon of promise and possibility
cars were surrounded by the unintended
consequences
it created that's exactly where we are
with technology today
full of potential but surrounded by the
unintended consequences it's created
for cars the responsibility was shirked
for decades
auto manufacturers looked the other way
government was slow to act
and the onus was on consumers the
drivers and pedestrians to
be more careful look where they're going
ultimately it was a work of mavericks
and stand-out individuals and
organizations that led to the change we
see today
so what can we learn from this well
first
it went on for far too long it took 50
years for a simple safeguard like seat
belts to be commonplace
in cars with the reach and scale of
technology
we can't afford 50 years but i also
learned
that safety sells safety and
responsibility
is good business would you buy a car
today that didn't have seat belts or
airbags
as consumers are becoming more aware of
the downstream effects of technology
safe tech is a competitive advantage and
building
and retaining their trust will soon be
non-negotiable
but most importantly i learned that the
responsibility
is on us as builders to create
responsible tech
because saying that the solution to tech
addiction is for consumers to just
manage their screen time
is the same thing as saying the solution
to car casualties is for drivers to
forego seat belts and just be a little
bit more careful
technology needs to be responsible from
the onset so over the last year
i've talked to hundreds of people in
this space gen z teenagers
tech ethicist heads of product to
understand what we can do to build
responsible technology i'll share three
things with you today
the first is we need to reimagine the
future the alternative to today's
reality
we need to take a step back and ask
ourselves questions like
what are the meaningful habits and the
intentional interactions that we want to
help foster
what are the products that we want our
kids and our grandkids to grow up with
and what does technology that we trust
actually look like
instead we're too focused on the here
and now
the quarterly earnings the annual
revenue
and those short-term views bring us
short-term solutions
so i challenge you to invite your team
to a meeting and brainstorm the idyllic
future
because with a clear vision of the
future that we want to build
we can shift from band-aid solutions to
long-term
transformations the second thing we need
to do
is measure what really matters we have a
natural tendency as technologists to
imagine
all the good that our products will do
for the world but once they launch
and reach scale we don't see the
negatives
we're surprised by them we're so focused
on building the car
that we ignore the traffic
so plan for that wild success treat
those edge cases
as core cases those extreme users as
core users
establish a risk mitigation process that
will help identify and surface
those hard to imagine consequences not
all risks can be avoided
but they can be anticipated
we also need to measure new things most
products have a north star metric
a singular metric that all teams are
striving to optimize
usually this comes in the form of
short-term engagement something like
time spent or number of sessions per day
and as a result the teams are over
optimizing
on moving that needle but when you over
optimize for that short term squeeze
you forget everything that comes at the
cost of that
and so instead of a single north star i
propose a metric constellation a set of
metrics that measures not just
engagement
but also digital well-being value
thresholds
and better usage habits because what
gets measured
gets managed and finally we need to be
champions
of caution silicon valley has a strong
bias for action
a tendency to release something
half-baked and test and iterate and test
and iterate
but while this is great for progress
it's dangerous for society
instead we need to prioritize veracity
over velocity
purpose over speed we need a culture
where it's okay to ask the tough
questions
a culture where we don't hide behind all
the good we're doing
a culture of responsibility because it's
the right thing to do
and it's good business so what does this
actually look like
think back to your team's last product
release
mine was a celebration that included
lots of cake
we would ship something on time and
under budget
but imagine if we set a norm where we
reward teams for shipping something late
because an ethical concern was surfaced
and fixed where we decide not to ship it
at all
because of the major causes it could
have on people
i say that that deserves cake
now it may sound a little bit trivial
but this is exactly the culture that
we'll need
to push the balance of possibility to
define new business models
and discover novel ways to provide value
to users
as technologists we can release a
product and millions of people will be
impacted
just like that technology is not born
bad
it reflects the interests behaviors and
desires
of its creators
as future entrepreneurs and investors
and technologists and change makers
all of you play a role in building the
future of responsible technology
i to be part of the problem to be
passionate about the solution
but whatever drives you i hope you'll
buckle up and join me on the ride
thank you
you